do you think she is now in a more
dangerous position because of what was
seeing happening in Iran I think that
there's a lot of instability now in
inside Iran itself you've seen the anger
spilling over from some of those
demonstrations yesterday people think
that their international reputation has
been damaged by the government trying to
cover up the the tragedy of the shooting
down of the plane I think we've been
seeing really since last but last
November some of that tension beginning
to bubble up internally and I think that
as mr. rattler said you've got a regime
that really doesn't think twice about
holding individuals as bargaining chips
how do you think the UK government
should be responding we've heard a lot
about de-escalation but of course things
stepped up with the arrest of the UK
ambassador well of course that was
indicative of a regime whose instincts
are to repress and cover-up but at the
same time they're having to do with the
realities of international law it's
illegal to arrest a diplomat and of
course with the investigation ongoing
about the crash it was impossible to
cover up there so you've got these two
things going on at the same time I just
hope that what we have at the moment
gives a moment for both sides to think
you're the best way forward for
everybody is to get back into some sort
of negotiated settlement but the prime
minister on the foreign centre-right to
say we need to de-escalate we've got to
find a diplomatic way through all of
this because the alternative would be
for the loss of human life do you think
and Donald Trump is making the world a
safer or more dangerous place
well the present of the United States
has a responsibility to protect his own
people and America is able to and has a
right to respond in self-defense and the
point I was making the other day was you
know that general Soleimani carried out
a lot of these things that proxy wars in
the Yemen the support of the Assad
regime support of Hezbollah who
themselves support the international
drug trade while he was part of this
regime and this is a dangerous position
if on top of that there was an imminent
risk to American military personnel or
diplomats the US has a right to respond
to that and the other debate of course
when you're talking about
Iran and their instinct to to cover
things up do you think it's credible
that Iran are claiming that they simply
must
this airport this aircraft this a
passenger jet carrying 176 people for a
missile is that is that credible I think
it's always possible to have human error
if you remember with the very
unfortunate tragic shooting down of the
Iranian aircraft by the American
military again that was a human error
rather than policy so I think we have to
accept that that is a possibility and
trying to move on from there okay and
and then we were talking to Brandon
Lewis earlier on the show the security
minister he was talking about the
importance of the Iranian nuclear deal
do you think that the UK government just
needs to accept that it's over it's not
happening well you know I said this out
in public and I've said it in the House
of Commons and I think that when the
u.s. withdrew from that deal it was dead
people some people say still on the
table
believe me I have spent enough time as a
doctor to know it just because you're on
the table doesn't mean you're gonna get
off successfully I think that we need to
look at a wider deal remember before the
Iranian nuclear deal the Iranians wanted
what they called the grand bargain that
looked at wider issues regional issues
and I think that we have to get back to
that I think that the the Iranian
nuclear deal was rushed partly because
it was the Americans wanted it done
before the end of the Obama presidency I
think we need to know to look at the
wider picture what's happening in the
region with Iran what's happening with
the other Gulf allies that we have there
what's happening with Israel how do we
get a wider and more regional settlement
okay now I want to talk about the speech
that you're getting this week it's all
about global Britain okay just explain
what it is you're gonna be talking about
well it's its first of two speeches
really the fesses and this one is about
how we organize Whitehall and how we
organize the civil service I think it's
a real opportunity for us with a new
role for Britain outside the EU and with
new functions including trade in our
world that's changing very rapidly to
look at how we organize Whitehall and
our structures of government and also
the role of the civil service post
brexit and see whether they need to be
changed my own view is that we need to
be looking at countries like France and
Sweden as examples of where you can get
some political appointees in the civil
service but to enable the government to
put forward its agenda and carry forward
its agenda more quickly and more
certainly do
part of the issue with the civil
services that many people there were
opposed to praxis and argument you made
before well I think that was an
institutional resistance of course it's
impossible for any of us to know how
much of that was an inherent resistance
in the civil service and how much they
were being egged on by some of my former
colleagues who didn't want rector to
happen either but nonetheless it's very
clear I think that even when you look at
other Westminster based systems like
Canada or Australia at those governments
tend to have more influence in the
implementation of policy than we do in
the UK you also want to see the Foreign
Office and the Department of
International Development merged is
there not a risk then that the aid
budget is effectively used for political
purposes no how the AIDS budget they
budget is used to set out in in a number
of agreements and of course in our own
legislation but what I think it would do
is I think it would give as a chance to
have a single foreign policy because if
you go to Africa for example you'll find
that they have a bit more interest in
talking to different than they have the
Foreign Office because if it has the
money I think bringing them two together
makes a lot of sense could be
synergistic and also if you are
represented by two cabinet ministers
instead of one you get a counterbalance
to the Treasury which might not be a bad
thing in Whitehall take for the price of
one and now of course you used to be the
international trade secretary Boris
Johnson says he wants to have a full
trade deal signed off with the EU by the
end of the year is that achievable
really it's achievable the questions are
not going to lie around issues of
tariffs or quarters which you would
normally get in a trade negotiation
that's normally what takes up a lot of
time it will really be around the
regulatory issues
it'll be about access to the single
market what's clear is that we will be
outside the single market therefore you
can't have what's called frictionless
trade there will be some friction in
that and the government set up they want
to minimize that but they want Britain
to be able to determine our regulations
therefore the concept of what's called
dynamic alignment
ie we automatically follow EU rules is
out the window as it should be because
it's incompatible with brett's itself
now of course you have previously served
in cabinet with Boris Johnson you didn't
back him as leader the concept of party
if you change your mind on him now
seeing him
as Prime Minister well I think that what
he's done is to deliver for the
Conservative Party in a way that but
some people doubted a huge majority
forest which has given us a moment in
politics a little bit like mrs.
Snatchers when we exam tonight well I
think I like many people underestimated
the sheer power he would have in
attracting voters and we now have an
opportunity to make the conservative
case with voters particularly in the
north of England in a way that we've not
been able to do not even in those
natural years and I think that that is a
tremendously important moment in our
politics so for the Conservative Party
something that we haven't had in more
than a generation so it's up to us to
make sure that we take full advantage of
that